le rocher de gibraltar regardait se
séparer une fille et un garçon motors n
était un baron un officier au service de
la russie un homme célèbre pour ses
affabulations pour la pièce l'auteur luc
rémois un fils qui vit des aventures
auquel il ne croyait pas
toute l'idée de ce spectacle c'est de
faire valoir de donner sa valeur à
l'imaginaire de dire que bien sûr on est
dans un monde très cartésien 2 et 2 font
toujours quatre alors chez mym charles
je ne savais jamais 4 et donc c'est
toute l'idée est là c'est de faire en
sorte de donner à entendre et à rendre
compte de des espaces mentaux qui sont
pas seulement notre monde quotidien
la pièce de fabrice melquiot mail
mapping et composition d'acteur et
plonge le spectateur dans un imaginaire
un moment de folie et sans un peu cinglé
mais en même temps ils sont cinglés
comme comme tout un chacun l'est où
devrait se permettre de la être en tout
cas alors évidemment on bien beaucoup on
peut parler beaucoup de l'enfance se
dire que l'on peut dire que les enfants
cette capacité de s'ennuyer puis
l'instant d'après se retrouve au lieu
d'un champ de bataille et puis me mets
faire les bruits et c'est vraiment
génial mais je pense qu'en tant
qu'adulte quand on se donne la
possibilité soit de rejouer avec des
enfants soient des tout seul donc
essayer de faire pareil on est assez
content et ça me fait beaucoup de bien
avec en toile de fond une relation
père-fils munchhausen fourmis davanture
à voir en famille de 7 à 77 ans
et là qu'est la définir